Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich es
ist Adventszeit und da hocke ich in der
kriminator sehr wunderbar ja
[Gelächter]
ich wollte heute mit dir mal über etwas
sprechen was wir immer wieder als Thema
haben aber nie wirklich sozusagen selbst
zum Thema gemacht haben Social Media und
speziell Twitter die Frage welche Rolle
Twitter spielt auch jetzt das ganze
Theater rund um den Verkauf von twittern
Elon Musk und so weiter wenn du dir die
Zahlen zu Social Media mal anguckst das
ist spektakulär wie viel Prozent der
Weltbevölkerung nutzen Social Media wie
viele Menschen sind das was denkst Du ja
also auf einmal
in Afrika Social Media nutzen also die
Hälfte der Weltbevölkerung dürfte das
schon genau
4,6 Milliarden schätzungsweise
alles unvorstellbar und da liegt
natürlich Facebook vorne ja knapp drei
Milliarden monatlich Instagram 1,5
Milliarden dann hierzulande auch
Facebook mit 47 Millionen sehr weit
vorne gefolgt von Instagram tiktok
mittlerweile hätte die chinesische
Plattform knackt global die eine
Milliardengrenze Twitter
436 Millionen Pinterest kurz dahinter
reddit ist auch so in dem Bereich das
heißt das spielt alles eine gigantische
Rolle
und eine der Gründe warum ich mal mit
dir darüber reden wolltest nicht nur
Elon Musk sondern was ich interessant
finde mit Blick zum Beispiel auf das was
in China gerade passiert
Social Media Spital eine große Rolle
die Chinesen tauschten sich aus über
tiktok viele viele der Bilder die wir
haben und Kriegen kriegen wir über
Social Media das ist gut und wir nutzen
auch diese Bilder dann aber die Frage
wer betreibt eigentlich diese
Plattformen und wie gehen die mit der
der dem chinesischen System mit mit der
KP und der Unterdrückung dieser Proteste
wie gehen die damit um und dann kriegst
du mit das beispielsweise Apple
offensichtlich die airdrop-funktion in
China
kurzzeitig wie es heißt oder auch über
längere Zeit eingeschränkt hat du weißt
was man mit AirDrop macht der man teilt
sozusagen Filme Content Inhalte ohne
über ein anderes großes Netzwerk gehen
zu müssen sondern einfach direkt von
Gerät
für die Zensur damit quasi nicht zu
entdecken
dann hörst du das Twitter beispielsweise
plötzlich lustige erotikposts macht um
die Leute irgendwie abzulenken so bei
Laune zu halten ja statt statt statt
kritischer Dinge und so weiter das heißt
da gibt es offenbar wenn man da mal
genauer hinschaut einen glasklaren
Interessenskonflikt ja jemand wie Elon
Musk verkauft einen Großteil seiner
Elektroautos mittlerweile in China Apple
wie Deutschland übrigens auch so apple
verkauft eine große Automarke der Welt
genau apple verkauft einen Großteil
seiner
iPhones in china baut sie auch dort ist
also ein ganz wichtiger wichtiger Faktor
5 Milliarden Dollar ja ein Viertel des
Gesamtumsatzes hat Tesla in den
vergangenen drei Monaten in China
wirtschaftet das heißt das was z.B auch
in Hollywood zu besichtigen ist und das
ist das ist das Thema dass mich gerade
so umtreibt du wirst ja in der
amerikanischen Unterhaltungsindustrie
jederzeit den Film hinten den großen
Hollywood Blockbuster und die Geschichte
ist voll davon der sich ganz ganz
kritisch mit der eigenen Regierung
auseinandersetzt ja Full Metal Jacket
und viele viele andere Filme oder Zero
da können die oder Filme und so weiter
oder die großartigen Filme hier Beweis
über die Trainee zum Beispiel genau ganz
toller Film genau oder hier hier
Catherine bigallo nur die die Frau von
von James Cameron dem dem Titanic
Regisseur die diesen Zero Duck thirty
gemacht hat diesen Film über die
Ergreifung von von Osama bin Laden ja
diese diese sonderoperation
spezialoperation in Abu Tabak in in
Pakistan das findest du genau so was du
nicht findest ist ein Film der sich
kritisch mit der Kommunistischen Partei
Chinas auseinandersetzt den findest du
nicht
warum 1,4 Milliarden Chinesen ein
gigantischer Markt niemand traut sich
sich der würde da auf diesem Markt
wahrscheinlich offiziell nicht machen ja
so ja und in den USA interessiert das
die Leute nicht und China kann man es
nicht so das meine ich und da ist
eigentlich das ganze Problem im Grunde
schon beschrieben was geht hier durch
den Kopf wenn du wenn man mal diese
Zusammenhänge allein diese Zusammenhänge
sich mal anschaut bevor wir darüber
reden was es eigentlich bedeutet wenn
etwas wie Twitter das im Vergleich
vielleicht eine eher kleine Plattform
ist was aber eine Plattform ist auf der
anderen Seite auf der soll mal die die
Meinungsführer dieses Planeten die Leute
die jeden Tag Meinung machen und auch
die Meinung bestimmen und die zum Teil
auch darüber befinden ob der Idiot des
Tages gerade mal Markus Lanz ist oder am
nächsten Tag jemand anderer ja diese
dieses Medium ist jetzt in der Hand des
reichsten Menschen auf diesem Planeten
der nebenbei
Motor Autos verkauft der Batterien
herstellen lässt der also sehr viel Geld
verdient mit ganz anderen Dingen
das waren ganz viele Fragen offen ja ich
weiß ich habe es nur mal so aufgerissen
an was mir durch den Kopf geht wenn ich
höre das über 4 Milliarden Menschen
Social Media nutzen das erste was mir
einfällt ist haben die alles so viel
Zeit
also ich meine früheren Jahrhunderten
war das doch so dann haben die Leute
sich tot gearbeitet da hatten sie außer
wenn sie Bergbauern in Südtirol waren
und im Winter in ihren Stuben gefroren
haben da hatten sie mal ein bisschen
Zeit füreinander ansonsten hatte man ja
eigentlich im Leben nie Zeit und ich
frage mich immer wenn die Leute heute so
viel Zeit haben überall in der Welt
woran liegt das und das zweite ist was
haben sie gemacht bevor es Social Media
Markt gab mit ihrer Zeit also wo wird
die Zeit weggenommen die für Social
Media Nutzung gebraucht wird ich finde
das eine sehr sehr spannende kennst du
die Zahl dazu das ist auch ganz
interessant der durchschnittliche Mensch
ja diese 4,62 Milliarden verbringen im
Schnitt das ist natürlich alles extrem
grobe zahlen aber ich glaube dennoch
dass man das schon ein bisschen
eingrenzen kann er bringt zweieinhalb
Stunden jeden Tag mit Social Media
894 Stunden im Jahr um sich zu
informieren auszutauschen Neuigkeiten zu
erfahren und dann am Ende natürlich
Produkte zu kaufen also ich erinnere
mich an einen Vortrag den ich mal gehört
habe von damaligen Deutschlandchef von
Facebook der ist schon einige Jahre her
und ich weiß nicht ob es noch aktuell
ist aber er hat so Kurven gezeigt und in
welchen Zeiten werden Social Media
damals in erster Linie Facebook am
meisten genutzt
und das ist während der Bürozeit ich
kann mir vorstellen es interessante ist
die Zeit in diesem allerwenigsten
genutzt wird ist samstags an
und und die das Fazit was er damals
gezogen hat ist dass das was in Social
Media abgeht 100 mal interessanter ist
als das was im Job abgeht aber das was
samstags abends abgeht immer noch
interessanter ist als dass das auf
Social Media abgeht
ich weiß nicht ob diese Weisheit noch
gilt und ob die Zahlen noch genauso
schlimm aber das fand ich ziemlich
interessant also im Grunde genommen
einer der Gründe willkommene schnelle
kleine Ablenkung vom Berufsalltag
interessant das wäre so eine Erklärung
zu der Frage was haben die Leute vorher
gemacht
das ist jetzt sozusagen eine
philosophische Frage sind wir natürlich
so ein bisschen haben wir keinen festen
Grund ne kein festen Boden unter uns
wenn wir darüber spekulieren weil du so
ganz genau weiß man das was ich ja nicht
die zweite Frage die du mir darin
gestellt hast die natürlich politisch
die wichtige Frage ist so viel Macht in
den Händen eines einzelnen so viel
kommunikativer Raum der jemanden privat
gehört ich mein Facebook war ja auch
vorher nicht öffentlich rechtlich ne das
muss man dazu sagen und Twitter war das
auch nicht und so das waren die alle nie
ne das heißt also mit dem Wechsel zu
Elon Musk ändert sich ja nicht die
Tatsache dass ich hier um eine Operation
handelt das war ja auch vorher schon so
sondern geht nur in die Hände von
jemandem über den wir für gelinde gesagt
ihre halten das macht die Sache so ein
bisschen komisch ich halte nicht für
ihre das ist ehrlich gesagt das was mir
mehr Sorgen macht in keinster Weise ist
ich hätte ich ja ich hätte ihn auf eine
bestimmte Art für ihre ich glaube dass
er ein unglaublich intelligenter
rationaler Mensch ist
dass er aber glaubt dass diese rationale
Intelligenz die einzige Intelligenz im
Leben ist und das ist die ist worauf es
ankommt also das was Philosophen
Instrumente Vernunft nennen ja also die
Verwertung und Vernutzung von allem mit
Hilfe von intelligentem Kalkül diese Art
von Denken hat dieser Mann
perfektionierter gehörte zu den großen
Spitzen Leuten seines Fachs es ist aber
so wenn man auf diesem Denken wahnsinnig
gute ist dann ist das wie so oft ne weil
das Leben nichts aufbaut wo ist die
Steine nicht woanders hier holt so dass
man in anderen Form von Intelligenz
meistens nicht ganz so gut ist ja
meistens ist man da nicht ganz so gut in
sozialer Intelligenz in Empathie in
ästhetischen Empfinden und was ist sonst
alles so gibt ne wo andere Leute ihre
Stärken haben und das irre besteht dann
darin wenn jemand der so viel Erfolg mit
einer bestimmten Art von Denken hat die
ganze Welt dann eigentlich nur noch aus
dieser Perspektive betrachtet und dann
bekommt Rationalität was ist
also das ist wie ich das sagen will ich
will dich nicht jetzt nicht sagen dass
der irgendwo hinter Gittern gehört
sondern dass irre ist das ist sozusagen
eine sich verselbstständigende Art des
Denkens also er hat es immer mal selbst
so beschrieben das fand ich ganz
interessant so dass Selbstbild von Elon
Musk der so sinngemäß immer mal gesagt
hat auf die Frage wer er eigentlich ist
pass auf ich ich bin jemand der
Elektromobilität eine neue Art der
Mobilität quasi erfunden und auf jeden
Fall Massen marktfähig gemacht hat und
ich bin jemand der Menschen in Raketen
setzt und sie irgendwann mal zu Maß
schießen will wird irgendjemand
ernsthaft glauben dass ich ein ganz
normaler Typ bin
okay er hält sich selbst im positiven
Sinne also das ist der Punkt das hat
Steve Jobs glaube ich auch gemacht
zum selbst zum Selbstbild große
augentropfeneure dass sie sich insofern
schon für ihre halten weil sie auch eine
gewisse Verachtung vor den normalen
haben
also dass jemand der der ganz normal ist
der wird nie ein großer Unternehmer
werden sondern ein bisschen Iris gehört
natürlich schon dazu zum Beispiel bei zu
einem solchen Unternehmertum natürlich
auch gehört keine Grenzen zu kennen was
ja so finden das Leben der meisten
Menschen nicht ganz unwichtig ist sich
innerhalb von Grenzen aufzuhalten und
Grenzen zu haben im Hinblick auf Moral
Grenzen zu haben im Sinne von genug ja
Grenzen zu haben im Sinne von gut
Zufriedenheit einsetzen und Hunger
nachlässt und so weiter und diese
Grenzen die davon ja in sich nicht
spüren wenn man so erfolgreich werden
will man muss ja dieses dieses
grenzenlose in sich haben und das hat
auch immer ein bisschen was anderes ja
ganz grundsätzlich Richard auch
philosophisch betrachtet für dich
persönlich was ist
Social Media für dich was ist Twitter
für dich ist es sowieso dieser Tage
immer formuliert hat ist es eine Fackel
der Freiheit ist es eine schrille Echo
Kammer der eigene Meinung ist es das was
du mal genannt hast an ein einer
gigantische narzissmusmaschine Sascha
sagt es ist eigentlich beides und das
ist das und das abstoßende gleichermaßen
ja nicht nur beides all das und auch
ganz vieles andere mehr also es ist eine
unglaublich redundanzmaschine
es ist ein eindrucksvoller Beleg dafür
dass Kommunikation keine Grenzen hat ja
also in keiner Hinsicht irgendwo dass
das Mitteilungsbedürfnis des Menschen
auch keine Grenzen hatte und keiner
Hinsicht und nirgendwo gesagt hat dass
wir in einer Welt leben in der die
Anzahl der der Ausgestoßenen
Informationen Informationen mal jetzt
ganz neutral betrachtet immer weiter
explodiert und explodiert und dass das
ein Fall ist auf den im Grunde genommen
unsere ganze Architektur unserer Staaten
unseres rechts und so weiter noch
überhaupt nicht vorbereitet sind man
darf ja nicht vergessen es gibt ja ein
ganz engen Zusammenhang zwischen der Art
und Weise wie ein Start funktioniert und
wie Öffentlichkeit organisiert ist also
im Mittelalter Demokratien quasi wieder
Iran ja in solchen in solchen
Situationen gab es keine Öffentlichkeit
es gab nur einen der der Wahrheiten
verkündete und wenn es auch Fake News
waren und das war die Kirche
aber trotzdem ist doch faszinierend
wenn man gebildet sein wollen aus
welchen Gründen auch immer dann konnte
man in der Klosterschule erzogen dann
macht man eine bestimmte akademische
Laufbahn muss die zehn Jahre in Paris ja
ein ein ein Fleiß kubikulum abarbeiten
in dem einem alles eingetrichtert wurde
anbegriffen und Denkstrukturen und
Kategorien und so weiter was die Kirche
könnte und dann konnte man dann für die
Kirche Arbeiten es war die einzige Form
sich intellektuell zu betätigen alles
auf dass sie Rechtsprechung war ja ob
das sie das Regeln von von
wirtschaftsbeziehung war für alles war
die Kirche zuständig es gab aber keine
Öffentlichkeit ich sage ja mal
Öffentlichkeit ist wenn gleiche über
gleiches reden ohne gleicher Meinung
sein zu müssen
und das gab es nicht erstens waren die
Leute nicht gleich es gab die Leute der
Kirche und den Rest ja und wenn man dann
über gleiches geredet hat was wichtig
dass man immer mehr oder weniger einer
Meinung war und solche Konflikte wurden
wenn man nicht einer Meinung war auch
schon mal mit Ketten und mit Schwert und
mit Feuer ausgetragen das heißt also
diese Gesellschaft hatte keine
Öffentlichkeit und Öffentlichkeit
entsteht bei uns ja erst als die
messestätte möglichst viele
Informationen brauchten für den Handel
und dann entstanden die ersten Zeitungen
das heißt eigentlich mit den ersten
Anfängen bürgerlicher Gesellschaft ja
von mir aus das Kapitalismus der hier
eine gute Rolle spielt ja damit beginnt
überhaupt das Bedürfnis nach dem freien
Austausch über bestimmte Dinge der jetzt
nicht reden ideologisch reglementiert
und dann entsteht die zeitungswelt und
die zeitschriftenwelt und ohne die jetzt
gerne Aufklärung gegeben ja und dann
entsteht im nächsten Schub zweite
industrielle Revolution elektronische
Medien also Radio und Fernsehen und
schon der Unterschied zwischen einer
Demokratie des Fernsehens eine Helmut
schmidtheit immer von fernsehdemokratie
gesprochen zu einer einer textbasierten
war schon ein riesen Unterschied auf
einmal war es wichtig wie man aussah als
Politiker und wie man im Fernsehen rüber
kam das waren ja alles Dinge die waren
die 150 Jahre vorher völlig egal gewesen
das hat sich ja alles verändert konnte
auch manipuliert werden ne wie Hitler
das Radio für sich genutzt hat berühmte
Volksempfänger und so weiter und dann
hat man aus dieser Erfahrung heraus
geradeaus hier Volksempfänger und
Erfahrung heraus öffentlich rechtlichen
Rundfunk in Deutschland gegründet um zu
sagen wir können das nicht dem freien
Spiel der Kräfte überlassen
ja wir brauchen wir brauchen etwas wie
wir wie wir diesen Markt auf möglichst
liberale und demokratische Art und Weise
gestalten damit hier sich nicht so
wiederholt dass irgendwelche Autokraten
an die Macht kommen oder Diktatoren oder
Volksverhetzung im großen Stil
stattfindet und so weiter und so weiter
und das ist ja über viele viele
Jahrzehnte einfach sehr gut gegangen wir
hatten eine private Presse die auf dem
Boden der freiheitlich demokratischen
Grundordnung stand und wir hatten ein
öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk ebenfalls quasi als Hüter der
Öffentlich Rechtlichen also der
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
und jetzt kommt Social Media und Social
Media ist global das ist nicht national
das ist ein großer Unterschied gehört
dann internationalen Firmen die man gar
nicht Firmen nennen kann Plattform für
Investitionskapital fluides
kapitalspekulatives Kapital und damit
gerät das jetzt alles aus den Fugen und
zurück zu dem Anfang zu freiheitsverkehr
oder nicht
schon das Internet hat das gezeigt was
Social Media auch zeigt in Diktaturen
und dem Autokraten ist das Internet und
Social Media ein unglaublicher seelisch
weil es freiheitsnischen schafft in
freiheitlichen Gesellschaften ist es
auch ein Segen aber eben auch ein Fluch
so würde ich es mein Diktaturen ich
glaube wir haben hier schon mal darüber
gesprochen ne das ist total interessant
über über Putin haben wir ja öfter
geredet ich glaube 80 Millionen Russen
nutzen Youtube 80 Millionen und wir
sehen Millionär nutzen ganz genau der
Rest nutzt es einfach als Entertainment
aber das ist ein so großer Faktor dass
sie sich schlicht nicht leisten können
das einfach abzuschalten im Iran ist es
ähnlich ne auch da gibt's Plattform die
kannst du den Leuten nicht nehmen die
kannst du nicht abschalten weil dann
hast du wirklich den Volksaufstand man
die Frage mit Social Media ist ja
wirklich interessant also
deswegen bin ich immer sehr vorsichtig
ich nutze das selber nur passiv
sozusagen ich ich lese und nutze das als
als Quelle für unendlich viel
Information und interessante Dinge aber
ich nutze es in keinster Weise aktiv
über die Rolle der Politik sollten wir
da in dem Zusammenhang auch gleich noch
mal sprechen das finde ich sehr sehr
genau wenn man weiß
wunderbar der Deutschen
bundestagsabgeordnet haben einen Account
bei Twist finde ich eine unglaubliche
Ehre aber aber das finde ich es nicht
eine einer Vertiefung auf jeden Fall
also was sucht ein
Bundestagsabgeordneter eigentlich bei
Twitter das finde ich eine spannende ich
habe ich habe ein ein Punkt wollte ich
eben noch machen Richard weißt das ist
natürlich
irgendwie auch etwas was insofern
faszinierend ist als man natürlich klar
haben muss oder klar ziehen muss auch
für sich auch selbstkritisch sagen muss
man man hat immer so den Reflex zu sagen
okay heute fallen sie wieder über mich
her und dann gibt es den bösen Shitstorm
und so weiter und und wenn du jetzt
gerade das Arschloch des Tages bist dann
kannst du dich warm anziehen
und und dich eigentlich unter einer
Bettdecke verkriechen oder am nächsten
Morgen kommst du dann wieder raus guckst
mal vorsichtig ob der Sturm vorbei ist
und das kann man alles beklagen und
Leute auch aus unserer Branche und so
weiter tun das gerne und sagen das ist
alles so unfair und und was die da
draußen wieder machen und die
moralpolizei und die sprach Polizei und
sie wissen alles besser und die die
Steinigung vom Sofa aus und so weiter ja
was da alles stattfindet andererseits
muss man mal sagen wenn du was zu sagen
hast wenn ich was zu sagen habe dann
haben wir unsere Kanäle dann haben wir
die Chance das zu tun so ist das so und
dann allermeisten genau haben die
allermeisten haben das nicht und
insofern ist es gut genau und das ist
der freiheitswert von Twitter ne das ist
absolut so der allergrößte Teil der
Bevölkerung hat nicht die Gelegenheit
über eine große Reichweite ihre Meinung
überall kund zu tun oder von vielen
gehört zu werden genau und da ist
natürlich Twitter eine exzellente Chance
dass das so ist das ist sozusagen wenn
man sich die Medaille anguckt die gute
Seite dieser Medaille was ich jetzt aber
nicht verstehe ist warum
Bundestagsabgeordnete das machen also
diese merkwürdige nee verstehe ich nicht
und zwar ist folgendem Grund wenn ich
mir mal angucke ab wann wurden Tweets
von Politikern
überhaupt
erstmal auf Twitter abgesondert hat
überhaupt etwas was als offiziell
offizielle Statement wahrgenommen wurde
erst mit Donald Trump 88 Millionen
followerne 88 Millionen mehr als alle
Zeitungen auf dem nordamerikanischen
Kontinent zu sichern mehr als alle
Bundestagsabgeordneten zusammen aber das
Interesse aber das Interesse auf Platz 1
steht das ist ja kommst du nicht drauf
okay aber das Interessante daran ist
doch dass man als Politiker ja die
Möglichkeit hat auf allen Ecken und
Enden seine Kommentare loszuwerden na
mit der Presse zu reden Pressemitteilung
zu machen und so weiter deswegen ist das
mit dem Twitter durchaus
erklärungsbedürftig aber zu Trump zurück
als in der Tagesschau oder in heute
irgendwelche Dinge die Donald Trump im
Wahlkampf auf Twitter abgesondert hatte
zu Nachrichten wurden habe ich die Hände
über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen
das sind doch private Mitteilungen
Twitter schreibt ist doch nicht die
Verlautbarung eines Opposition
amerikanischer Präsident war erst recht
das ist doch keine presseer Sprung des
Weißen Hauses das ist doch nicht was der
Regierungssprecher als offizielle
Meinung
eines Präsidenten von sich gibt sondern
das ist irgendwas dahin gerotztes ja in
einem privaten Medium es wurde aber von
der Weltöffentlichkeit auch weil es so
leicht skandalisierbar war weil es ist
genüsslich ja zitiert diskutiert zum
Gegenstand von Talkshows gemacht und so
weiter und damit wurde die Grenze
zwischen offiziellem regieren und
privater Meinungsäußerung total
verwischt und ich glaube dass diese
Grenze nicht unwichtig ist dass sie
eingehalten wird wenn was ist dann der
öffentliche Raum wenn jede private
Äußerung genauso behandelt wird wie eine
offizielle Regierungserklärung dann
verwischt sich alles und auf einmal
entsteht nur noch ein wüstes Potpourri
von Meinungen und Stimmungen und der Ton
verändert sich ja man wird immer
unverfrorener mit dem was man sagt muss
ja nur welchen Ton falls ich Donald
Trump geäußert hat gibt auch einige
andere ich erinnere mich an einen
ukrainischen Botschafter mit einer
seltsamen Berufsauffassung der der genau
auf die gleiche Art und Weise
polymisiert hat als diplomending meinst
du ja ja das sind doch Dinge wo man sagt
da haben wir was da totaler Vorfall der
Sitten und wahrscheinlich ist es mehr
als ein Verfall der Fitness auch ein
Verfall der politischen Kultur
[Musik]
wie heißt interessant ich kennst du
kennst du den Satz von Hubertus Heil
dazu in unserem Arbeitsminister
hat
Italien
ist irgendwas drauf und dann hast du ab
ja das das ist das was er dazu gesagt
hat ich habe heute mit morgen hat er
selber
ich müsste ich jetzt überprüfen aber ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher Lukas schaut
danke
in der Regie und und verfolgt uns ähm
ich bin mir sicher dass er einen hat und
der der Punkt ist ab heute morgen mit
meinem Sohn darüber gesprochen und der
sich ganz viel auch mit diesen Dingen
beschäftigt und sagte Papa tut das
erstmal gewaltige hassmaschine
eine gewaltige hassmaschine und dann
fingen wir aber an eben genau über
dieses andere zu reden dass wir gerade
hatten ja also als Thema zu sagen pass
auf es ist aber auch ein einem ein
wichtiges Werkzeug ja um Menschen eine
Stimme zu geben die sonst vorher eben
keine hatten und die Frage aber das ist
natürlich schon interessant warum nutzt
Politik das ich meine es gibt so
Hinweise darauf warum das so sehr
genutzt wird ja also 80 Prozent der
Bundestagsabgeordneten haben einen
solchen Account Hubertus Heil hat
selbstverständlich nicht anhören auch
ein Account danke Lukas okay und es gibt
einen der das Medium so
beherrscht könnte man sagen wie kein
anderer wer ist das
im Deutschen Bundestag Minister
Deutschland Bundestag der der am meisten
twittert ja ich habe eine Befürchtung
genau ja Karl laut richtig eine Million
voller
und dann muss man die Frage stellen
kannst du ihm ja gerne dabei sein nicht
selten Gast in einer Sendung mal fragen
warum er das eigentlich weil er hat ja
tausend andere Möglichkeit dann könnt
ihr jeden Tag könnte der 10 offizielle
Erklärungen Interviews und so
weitergeben warum macht man das weil
erklären ja kann man Gesundheitspolitik
in 280 Zeichen nicht
ja ich hatte noch mal kurz die Rolle von
Twitter in dem Zusammenhang und und Karl
Lauterbach ne Konstantin von nutzt der
sich bei den Grünen um digitalpolitik
kümmert der sagt ohne Twitter wäre Karl
Lauterbach womöglich nicht
Gesundheitsminister geworden
also muss man muss man fürchten muss man
fürchten unsichtbar zu werden als
Abgeordneter oder als politischer zwei
Sachen pass auf es gibt wenn man nicht
in Talkshows ist und nicht twittert ja
ich glaube ja tatsächlich ist das so
Marius Selzer kennst du dens Mannheimer
Sozialwissenschaftler der hat
interessanter Mann der hat 1,2 Millionen
Tweets mal von Kandidaten für die
Bundestagswahl ausgewertet und sagt
zwischen 2013 und 2021 also wenn man
grob in den letzten sieben acht Jahren
hat sich der Anteil des negativ Camping
ja also ein Politiker fällt über den
anderen her mehr als verdoppelt und
gesagt im vergangenen Wahlkampf
hat dieses negativ companing ungefähr
14% aller Tweets ausgemacht das heißt er
sagt das ist das beste Medium um sich
über andere lustig zu machen aber lustig
zu machen in dem Fall irgendwie oder
vermisstisch und verharmlos sind ne auch
um andere Leute schlicht oder greifen zu
die Familien oder in irgendeine komische
Ecke zu drücken ja und das ein bisschen
schade daran ist Demokratie in Leben
natürlich vom streiten das unterscheidet
ja von Autokratien aber leben vom wohl
meinen Streit auf der Suche nach guten
Lösungen und Twitter ist nicht das
Medium des wohlmeinenden Streits wie du
gerade sehr schön an den Zahlen
dokumentiert hast ja sondern dies fiesen
Streits des fertigmachens Personen in
Frage stellens und so weiter und aus
dieser Perspektive muss man sagen die
Auswirkungen von Twitter für unsere
Demokratie sind schwer abzuschätzen aber
zu befürchten
es war mir Sorgen um den wohl meinen
Streit in diesem Jahr du hast nur du
hast gerade gefragt warum man das macht
Trump hat das mal so angedeutet und der
hat das auch als einer der ersten finde
ich so glasklar.ant wo die große Chance
ist die große Chance liegt natürlich
darin genau das zu umgehen was sozusagen
einordnen ist was kontextualisieren ist
du kannst ungefiltert einfach genau das
sagen was du in dieser Sekunde sagen
möchtest es gibt keine kritische
Nachfrage es gibt keine kritische in
Ordnung es gibt niemanden der die auf
den Keks geht du haust es einfach raus
und du machst es vormittags um 11 Uhr
ja es ist ein feiges Medium weil für den
wohl meinen Streit man sich mit jemanden
zusammensetzen muss oder ihn gegenüber
sitzen muss und auch die Gegenargumente
aushalten muss und hier haut man einfach
noch raus und dann verabschiedet man
sich und dann geht es einem anschließend
besser man könnte natürlich annehmen
dass es vielleicht sozialhygienisch was
positives hat dass derjenige der sein
hasst dann abgeladen hat anschließen der
zu seiner Frau ist also sozusagen der
Frust raus ist vielleicht könnte man
sagen dass diese Blitzableiter Funktion
vielleicht eine gute Funktion für die
Gesellschaft hat die müsste man
vielleicht mit einrichten Ich habe eine
andere Theorie ich hatte Dich
wenn man sich ernsthaft auch mal als wir
auch als als sozusagen klassische Medien
damit auseinandersetzt da muss man ja
mal sagen also zwei Punkte das eine ist
und darüber denke ich viel nach und da
reden wir häufig in der Redaktion
darüber bei Trump haben wir noch muss
man mal wirklich selbstkritisch sagen
einen gigantischen Fehler gemacht und
wir sind dabei den Fehler immer und
immer wieder zu machen müssen wir
wirklich über jedes Stöckchen springen
das uns irgendjemand hinhält absolut
meine Meinung wir hätten das was er auf
Twitter verbreitet nicht zum Gegenstand
offizieller Nachrichten machen
das meine ich wirklich weil damit konnte
er die Öffentlichkeit in den USA aber
auch weiter darüber hinaus manipuliert
genau
weiter verbreiten muss man das genau
muss man das ja jetzt würden wir
natürlich die Nachrichten Redaktionen
sagen ja aber wir werden wenn ihr da was
abenteuerliches rausgehauen hat und ja
dann ist das ja eben dann ist das
natürlich Wahnsinn dann klicken die
Leute das an darf man ja nicht vergessen
ja also wenn wir mal das öffentlich
rechtliche Herausrechnen der aller aller
größte Teil des Medienmarktes ist privat
in den USA sowieso und privater
Medienmarkt lebt davon dass man
möglichst hohe Klickzahlen hat oder eine
Zeitung verkauft man ja kaum noch also
mit anderen Worten in einer
Aufmerksamkeit Ökonomie muss man sehen
dass man immer vorne mitspielt und wenn
Trump dann so ein schönes Hotel liefert
dann denkt man nicht staatstragend
darüber nach sondern dann sieht man die
und es geht um Geschwindigkeit und wer
ist als erster raushaut in dem ist die
Aufmerksamkeit in unserer
Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie sicher
aber meine These wäre ja Richard also es
ist ja gibt ja sozusagen immer dieses
Klagen der klassischen Medien ja über
über Social Media und über das Internet
und ich weiß noch als das damals losging
da war ich noch bei RTL und hat uns oft
darüber unterhalten über immer die Frage
was wollen wir eigentlich sein auch als
fernsehen wollen wir jemand sein der
sozusagen seine eigenen Geschichten
erzählt dann haben wir gemerkt okay wir
kommen da immer öfter ins Hintertreffen
die sind schneller ja die die
Nachrichten verbreiten sich quasi in
Echtzeit ungefilter das wird einfach
gesendet völlig egal heute auch bei bei
jeder Katastrophe die passiert selbst
bei Dingen wo noch nicht mal klar ist
was da eigentlich wirklich passiert die
Jüngste ist Beispiel der Anschlag der
Rakete in Polen die man oft Twitter war
der dritte Weltkrieg schon da das ging
unglaublich das gefährlich ging
unglaublich schnell ja man wusste sofort
wer es getan hat genau und das dann
diese Zeit nehmen wir uns nicht mehr als
ob das jetzt Bundestagsabgeordnete sind
die dann was von auch schon Raketen
twittern oder ob das tatsächlich
inoffiziellen Nachrichtenportalen
auftaucht beides ist ja passiert zeigt
wie wenig solche Informationen heute
noch geprüft werden wenn die Erregung da
ist ja dann dann fehlt das kühle
Bewusstsein zu sagen erstmal genau
gucken was ist das für eine Quelle und
stimmt das oder stimmt das nicht das
kannst du vielem vielen weißt du was
total interessant ist diese Geschichte
ne gab ja Leute Marie agents stark
Zimmermann zum Beispiel hat dann sowieso
sofort getwittert so jetzt müssen wir
gucken ob das jetzt nicht der NATO
Bündnis Fall ist und so weiter also
sinngemäß ne bitte ich zitiere nicht
wörtlich aber so ist es bei vielen
Leuten angekommen das heißt da war
sozusagen das Bedürfnis da ganz schnell
die Nachricht zu setzen du kannst dir
nicht vorstellen wie oft ich dieser Tage
im im Hintergrundgespräch mit Leuten aus
der ersten Reihe der Politik den Satz
hören ich bin ja so froh dass ich mich
im letzten Moment am Riemen gerissen
habe weil eigentlich wollte ich auch
sofort als dieser Rakete da in Polen
plötzlich gelandet ist
hatten viele viele aus der ersten Reihe
der Politik das Gefühl jetzt muss ich
ganz schnell und ganz dringend was dazu
sagen und am Ende war dann doch die
Vernunft da die dazu führte bei den
meisten dass ich es nicht getan haben
einige konnten nicht widerstehen mussten
es dann später ziemlich klein laut
wieder zurücknehmen und haben sich dann
noch dafür entschuldigt und dann ist
auch gut aber tatsächlich hat das
gezeigt wie schnell dieses ganze Medium
ist das ist das eine aber die andere
Seite Richard darüber würde ich gerne
mal mit dir reden ist es nicht so und
das habe ich im damals gemerkt als wir
anfingen uns viele Gedanken darüber zu
machen ich habe irgendwann für mich
Begriffen ich war damals bei RTL auch in
in
ziemlich großer redaktioneller
Verantwortung ich war relationsleiter
und irgendwann habe ich für mich so
begriffen
es ist egal was wir machen dieses neue
Medium wird immer schneller immer
skrupelloser und immer
dreckiger sein im Zweifel als wir es
jemals sein könnten das heißt da gibt
ein neues Medium ein Tempo vor das
werden wir niemals Einholen der hat das
dieses Rennen werden wir verlieren du
meinst jetzt das Rennen zwischen
reflektierender Urteilskraft und im Raum
aber versuchen Meldungen genau also wenn
das Internet sozusagen anfing immer
steilere Thesen immer härtere Bilder
immer immer skrupelloser immer mehr in
die in die Vollen immer mehr auf die 12
dann wäre ja der Reflex zu sagen okay
das jetzt eine neue Konkurrenz ja die
die jagen uns Zuschauer ab die jagen uns
Aufmerksamkeit ab jetzt müssen wir da
auch rein und noch schneller und noch
besser und noch härter und irgendwann
habe ich ziemlich schnell für mich
zumindest analysiert dieses Rennen
kannst du niemals gewinnen weil wir
werden immer die Pflicht haben
nochmals zu gucken was sind die Quellen
wo kommen diese Bilder wirklich her was
ist der Kontext wir müssen überprüfen
was der Wahrheitsgehalt einer Geschichte
ist oder was er nicht ist und dann ist
klar du kannst dieses Rennen eigentlich
nur verlieren weil als als Medium auch
als privater Fernsehsender wirst im
Zweifel von der Landesmedienanstalt und
von von Journalistenverband und von
anderen führst du zur Rechenschaft
gezogen du bist ja für das
verantwortlich was du da tust im nähere
richtig nicht passieren genau aber
selbst wenn du zur Rechenschaft gezogen
bist also viel passiert aber das willst
du nicht Richard nee pass auf nee nee da
kann ich dir als jemand der wenn du
deinen Verantwortung bist das willst du
nicht du willst keine Abmahnung der
Landesmedienanstalt haben du willst
keine Gegendarstellung veröffentlichen
müssen und zwar das willst Du alles
nicht gut aber deswegen heißt man sich
ne genau da ist der selbstproduzent von
den Informationen der auf Twitter ist ja
niemanden verantwortlich seinem Gewissen
nur wenn er eins hat genau ja und
ansonsten kann er da im Prinzip sehr
ich glaube es gibt bestimmte Grenzen die
kann er nicht überschreiten aber kann
sehr weit gehen und das hat sich
natürlich verändert das kann man sagen
ja aber vielleicht verändert sich ja so
ähnlich wie Gewalt im Fernsehen
nochmals Beispiel früher war das so wenn
so ein Derek oder ein Tatort war in den
70er Jahren kaum eine Leiche gesehen
kein Blut ja da gab es auch keine
durchgeknallten Massenmörder und Kinder
glaube ich wurden auch nicht umgebracht
und so weiter heute ist genau das
Gegenteil der Fall das heißt die
Menschen haben sich heute einen
unglaubliche gewaltloses jeden Abend
sterben in Ihrem Fernseher über 100
Leute zum Teil auf bestialische Art und
Weise und es sind ungefähr gleich
aufregend wie man das in den 70er Jahren
gefunden hat und es heißt also es gibt
so die alltägliche Dose ist an außer
alltägliches nicht ihre oder wird
eigentlich immer höher wie viel so
gemordet wird im deutschen Fernsehen
eher unglaublich ich gucke das will ich
gucke keine Krimis also ich habe ich
habe eine starke Abneigung gegen Krimis
ist nicht mein Genre weil du Angst hast
danach nachher unter der Bettdecke
kaufen kann nehmen wahrscheinlich weil
ich mich an die alltägliche Dosis nicht
gewöhnt habe weil irgendwann ist das ja
normal aber abgesehen davon also es gibt
wird dann so eine Gewöhnung eintreten
das heißt also die erregungskurven
werden immer höher und höher und höher
und die Menschen werden da so mitwachsen
ja und die Erregung wird dann die
gleiche sein wie als wenn sich früher in
der Elefantenrunde Politiker sich den
Rauch ihrer Zigaretten ins Gesicht
geblasen haben ja wo man sich aufgeregt
hat wie konnte der Kohle das sagen oder
der Schmidt oder der Brand und heute
benutzt man ganz andere Kategorien macht
jemand total fertig erklärt jeden für
unfähig für für moralisch diskriminiert
und und und aber es ist schon ein paar
Tage später auch nicht mehr wichtig dass
sie ihr hattet Umgangs verändert sich
und es wäre ja irre zu glauben dass sie
sich nur in den Medien verändert und die
Gefahr besteht darin wenn sich allgemein
so Form des Umgangs ändern wenn sich
Normen verschieben dass ich diese Normen
auch im allgemeinen Umgang verschieben
und dann würde ich natürlich sagen gut
jetzt bin ich auch nicht mehr der
Jüngste na irgendwann muss ich in dieser
Welt nicht mehr leben und vielleicht ist
das für die BürgerInnen ja nicht so
schlimm weil die ja schon von sich aus
daran gewöhnt sind aber ob unsere
liberale Demokratie darauf gut
vorbereitet ist auf diese
normverschiebung im Hinblick auf
Erregungen im Hinblick auf Aggressionen
im Hinblick auf unverantwortliche
Beleidigungen und so weiter da bin ich
nicht ganz sicher also die Sorge werde
ich nicht los ich
hab trotzdem noch mal etwas andere
Perspektive darauf Richert und er wird
gerne
in unsere Diskussion ist reinwerfen ja
könnte es sein dass uns Twitter Social
Media ganz allgemein das die auch also
den klassischen Journalismus auch besser
gemacht hat
war das eine steile These ich habe ja
wie du weißt ein Buch geschrieben dass
sie gestern Gegenteil ausgeht nämlich wo
ich die Gefahr sehe dass die
Qualitätsmedien zunehmend die Erregung
des Kurse der sozialen Medien reiten und
das dadurch qualitätsvorflachung damit
einhergeht und jetzt bin ich total
gespannt auf meine was dein gegen
Gedanken ja also tatsächlich ist es so
nicht ich also ich fange mal anders an
als wir angefangen haben mit unserer
Sendung da habe ich öfter erlebt dass
dann Spitzenpolitiker wenn es dann so
eine Passage in einem Gespräch gehabt
und kam der schon mal relativ unverblümt
mit der mit der Idee an nach der Sendung
das können wir doch hier rausschneiden
da habe ich nicht richtig gut ausgesehen
das kommt doch jetzt einfach da
rausnehmen
das habe ich natürlich immer alles
sofort zurückgewiesen wie als Redaktion
beißen das sofort zurück logischerweise
das Hunter Weise und irgendwie habe ich
das Gefühl da gibt es ein Zusammenhang
mit dem Aufkommen von Social Media mit
einer zunehmend das ist ja nämlich der
positive Aspekt dabei an der eine
Öffentlichkeit die kritischer wird die
Dinge genauer hinterfragt und ich würde
sogar die thesewagen das ist natürlich
die Zuspitzung gibt auf wenige Zeichen
der der schnelle Kohle Spruch und so
weiter über den sich die Leute dann auch
mal amüsieren aber am Ende in Summe ist
es natürlich so wenn du die Sonne
so ein Verlauf einer sende Besprechung
oder einer einer einer Gegenrede zu
irgendeinem Auftritt eines Politiker z.B
das mal anguckst in der Summe wenn du
die vielen Leute nimmst die da so
schreiben auch in den Kommentar leisten
ganz vieles Müll
aber unterm Strich ist dann doch immer
der eine der zweite der dritte der
vierte der fünfte kluge gute Gedanke
dabei das heißt es führt zu mehr
Differenzierung und das bedeutet dass
auch wir uns in den klassischen Medien
um diese Differenzierung wirklich
bemühen müssen und wenn wir missträden
und wenn Dinge nicht eindeutig klar sind
wenn wir nur was vermuten Glauben denken
das dann wird es in der aller nächsten
Sekunde von dieser genau von dieser
kritischen Öffentlichkeit in der Luft
zerrissen erstens und zweitens dann aber
auch richtig gestellt und wenn du jetzt
mal zum Beispiel auch an die Vorgänge
rund um die Kölner Silvesternacht zum
Beispiel denkst und es gibt viele viele
weitere Beispiele dafür
wo du gesehen hast okay da gibt es also
im Fall der Kölner Silvesternacht gab es
eindeutig an ein mediales Versagen der
klassischen Medien eindeutig ist auch
viel besprochen und gut untersucht
und es war dann es waren dann die
Stimmen aus dem Netz die dann in vielen
Fällen dazu geführt haben und sagt okay
bitte was sagen die da lass uns doch
noch mal bitte genauer hingucken was
sind das für Bilder lass uns doch bitte
auch da noch mal genauer hingucken also
deswegen die These also ich verstehe
natürlich gut weil wir die auch in
unserem Buch behandeln also es gab
zunächst mal hatten die waren ja
Silvester Nacht waren die klassischen
Redaktionen nicht besetzt und deswegen
war das tatsächlich so es gab ein
Informationsvorsprung in den sozialen
Medien und in den sozialen Medien
konnten natürlich viele Betroffene ihre
Perspektive schildern und dadurch wurde
das ganze Bild vielschichtiger und auch
anders als die der Polizei Sprecher z.B
das am Anfang sagen wollte oder das war
so ein offizielle Quelle ne für die
normalen Leitmedien allerdings weiß auch
gleichzeitig so dass von Leuten die
dabei waren oder meinten dabei gewesen
zu sein oder jemand zu kennen der dabei
gewesen ist auch Wahn ziemlich viele
Fake News in die Welt gebracht auch die
dann wieder ihren Weg in die
Qualitätsmedien gefunden haben die ja
nicht in der Lage waren in der schnellen
Zeit dass eine vom anderen zu
unterscheiden von Mainz immer schneller
immer skrupelloser und immer abgezockter
sein als es ein klassisches Medium
jemals sein kann es funktioniert nicht
also ich würde das von beiden Seiten
sehen also ich würde so gesehen das ist
Social Media geholfen hat die Brisanz
der der Silvesternacht sehr viel
schneller und deutlicher klar zu machen
das ist aber nicht unbedingt dazu
geführt hat dass da anschließend mehr
Wahrheit dabei rausgekommen wäre
jedenfalls unmittelbar darauf ja also es
gab Überschriften wie 1000 Männer aus
magreb Staaten vergewaltigen und so
weiter als hätten das alle tausend
gemacht und so weiter oder das sofort
hergestellt wurde zwischen denen die auf
der
Domplatte Frauen angegrabscht haben und
Handys geklaut dass das alles
geflüchtete aus Syrien gewesen sein und
so weiter und so weiter und das sind
auch so Verlinkungen die in Social Media
produziert genau sind das ist die andere
Seite nicht mehr
da wurde sofort Merkels
Flüchtlingspolitik in unmittelbarer eins
zu eins-beziehung gesetzt und sowas
nicht genau nicht dass wir uns hier
missverstehen dass darüber sollten auch
gleich noch mal sprechen auch gerade im
Bezug auf Twitter sehr interessant was
da direkt nach der Übernahme durch Elon
Musk dann auch da passiert ist aber der
der der Anstoß einfach nur mal zuschauen
okay was war denn da jetzt wirklich lass
uns doch bitte mal genauer hingucken
habe da möglicherweise was übersehen der
kommt natürlich häufig mittlerweile aus
dem Netz und das empfinde ich durchaus
als Bereicherung und das ist etwas von
dem ich sagen würde das macht uns da
auch besser ja
weil weil du kannst es dir nicht mehr
leisten den interner Form träge zu sein
weil es wird sofort entlarvt und
dekodiert und inzwischen auch richtig
gestellt da bin ich bei Dir und
eigentlich ist es ja so dass wir sagen
es ist doch eigentlich toll dass jeder
die Möglichkeit hat das was er denkt was
er gesehen hat
Wasser wahrgenommen hat medial zu
verbreiten das haben wir auch schon
gesagt dass die gute Seite der Medaille
und die spannende Frage ist nur wie
kriegen wir mehr verantwortungskultur da
rein und ist das überhaupt möglich
damit ist keine negative Seite der
Medaille ich sag dir mal die negative
Seite ja also
das ist schon verrückt du erinnerst dich
an den Angriff auf den Ehemann von Nancy
pelos in San Francisco was interessant
ist ist
mask hat dann kurz darauf verlinkt auf
Twitter zu seiner irren Webseite in der
dann behauptet wurde
sie sei ein Wahrheit betrunken gewesen
und das ganze war ein streiten mit
irgendeinem Callboy völlig übel viel zu
übel um es eigentlich in Bad
weiterzugeben und darüber zu sprechen
aber trotzdem muss man es einmal sagen
ist dieselbe Webseite die 2016 behauptet
hatte dass Hillary Clinton gestorben sei
und das hinter der Debatte in der
Fernseh Debatte mit Trump durch ein Body
double ersetzt worden war es völlig irre
das hat Maske einfach mal ganz kurz so
verlinkt hat dann klein laut wieder
runtergenommen aber das kann der dann
ist dann ist es kann auch ohne dass ihm
das Ding gehört hat aber es hat
natürlich eine andere Aufmerksamkeit
wenn das der neue Chef von Twitter macht
ohne Missbrauch verliert ihren Reiz
ja also wenn ich mir schon Twitter
Leiste für über 40 Milliarden dann
leiste ich mir auch solche Verlinkungen
weil sie ohne Twitter jetzt speziell
mache ich halt meine die
Faszination glaube ich von Twitter war
ja in der Vergangenheit doch eher dass
man sagte okay da ist eigentlich etwas
das ist weitestgehend eben nicht
reglementiert
ja gut wie alles das war ja auch am
Anfang beim Internet ja genau also ich
war nicht im Internet standen
Leute die eine große freiheitsträume
hatten zum Teil geträumt aus rote Mohn
und die sich so so links libert her
würde ich sagen ja irgendwas was es
heute nicht mehr so richtig gibt ja aber
das war ja so wie der Geist der mal
dahinter stand so jenseits der Macht und
jemand jenseits der mächtigen ja den
Raum zu öffnen also nicht die
ursprünglich Erfindung des Internets sie
ist militärisch aber diejenigen zu sagen
wir machen das Internet sozusagen für
alle und zugänglich und so weiter also
da war ja so ein bisschen so der große
Sommer idealen Anarchie an diesem Traum
hat es ja tatsächlich mal gegeben ja und
es ist natürlich in den ewigen Frühling
der Werbung übergewechselt und es ist
natürlich eben nicht der nicht der
Sandkasten der Anarchisten geworden ja
sondern das ist die die
Lieblingsspiel Stelle der Mächtigen und
der supermächtigen geworden wie immer im
Leben ich meine das kann man sagen
twitter ist würdest du sagen twitter ist
wichtig für die Demokratie
ja das würde ich schon sagen
twitter ist ja eigentlich eine schwierig
ne nur technisch ist es ja nicht
schwierig
die Frage ist warum gibt es keine
öffentlich-rechtlichen Social Media
nein die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen sind auf
Social Media
aktiviert mit einem europäischen Twitter
ja quasi öffentlich-rechtlich was ist
deine warum warum gelingt das nicht sag
mal warum ist das warum gibt es kein
europäisches Google warum gibt es keine
europäisches Facebook
Maschinen auf die keiner geht ne also
existieren aber das ist hoch interessant
also man sagt natürlich gut wenn wenn
die anderen schneller sind und wenn Sie
diese wahnsinnige Reichweite haben und
wenn sie so wahnsinnig schön und
benutzerfreundlich sind warum wie soll
sich dann ein Konkurrenzprodukt auf
diesem Markt auf dem einen perfektes
Produkt ist ja wie sollen sich das
überhaupt drauf etablieren dass der eine
Grund in der zweite Grund ist dass die
Europäische Union das ziemlich
bürokratisch angegangen ist also alle
Pläne müssen erstmal alle Ruhe abstimmen
und dann werden Gremien gebildet und so
weiter und so macht man das natürlich
nicht ja also das sozusagen der dem
freien Unternehmergeist dermaßen viele
viele gesetzt und wenn man gerade auf
dem auf dem technischen Stufe ankommt
auf der die sozialen Netzwerke heute
sind dann sind die schon wieder in zwei
drei Jahren meilenweit entfleucht das
war ich meine
es ich bin da immer so hin und her
gerissen ich denke einerseits wenn jetzt
jemand wie Elon Musk zum Beispiel der
aus seiner Bewunderung aus seinem
fanboytum für jemanden mit Trump in
großen Hill gemacht hat der auch in der
corona-pandemie heißt eine sehr
zweifelhafte Rolle gespielt hat der
selber auch zweimal an Corona krank ist
glaube ich ganz nebenbei der der viele
merkwürdige Dinge tut und auf der
anderen Seite dieses genialische hat
über das wir gerade gesprochen hat wenn
der jetzt diese Macht über diesen
Algorithmus hat und wenn er jetzt zum
Beispiel sagen würde nur jetzt rein
theoretisch damals Gedankenspiel er
würde sagen verändere diesen Algorithmus
so dass Richard David Brecht wenn er da
drauf geht einfach immer so diesen
diesen Rechten und rechtsradikalen
Content angezeigt kriegt ja
Algorithmus wird einfach so manipuliert
oder programmiert dass er das einfach
macht dann kann er das tun
andererseits und da kommt dann halt
wieder die Kraft des Marktes ins Spiel
welcher Werbekunde sollte seine Anzeige
schalten wollen unter einem Post an ist
Nazis niemand genau deswegen wird man
wahrscheinlich auch aus rein
ökonomischen Gründen bestimmte Grenzen
aber das ist doch aber man wird es
subtil machen aber nein man wird man
wird wunderbar manipulieren können auf
so subtile Art und Weise dass man
Werbekunden nicht verschreckt also die
Hoffnung dass der Markt das regelt ja
dass man sagt die Leute werden nur
dauerhaft nur dauert nämlich dort nur
dauerhaft dort werden ja wo alles in
aller beste Ordnung ist das stimmt nicht
die werden vor allen Dingen da werden wo
irrsinnige Reichweite ist und nur wenn
es krass ist der Regel Verstöße gegen
Grundwerte und sowas gibt ja dann wird
es sozusagen Kritik geben und auch die
wird dann irgendwann wieder verschwinden
und dann nicht mal wieder die Reichweite
die Reichweite und die Reichweite also
ich glaube nicht dass es eine moralische
Selbstregulierung des Marktes auf
Twitter gibt das glaube ich nicht das
wäre eine schöne Idee wenn es so wäre
aber ich glaube das was heißt damit
anderen Worten wenn wir festhalten also
wirklich auch das hasspotential ich sage
bewusstpotenzial von Twitter das ist
gigantisch und es gibt Leute fragt sich
immer warum gibt es so viele aggressive
unzufriedene Menschen dann könnt ihr
vielleicht mal sagen oder es ist so dass
alle unzufrieden und so weiter
proportional stark bei Twitter ist und
wir dadurch natürlich eine verfälschte
Wahrnehmung davon kriegen
falls Balance ja jetzt passt mal wieder
ich glaube wenn man muss sich nur auf
Twitter aufhält muss man ein total
mieses Menschenbild kriegen ja das ist
definitiv so aber ist das nicht generell
wenn man Medien konsumiert dass man dann
mieses Mädchen kriegen könnte
ein bisschen schon oder wenn wir mal
ganz ehrlich sind ich habe heute selber
aber nicht vom Hören unseres Podcasts
natürlich
raus aber ganz grundsätzlich wenn wir
sagen da gibt es wirklich dieses
hasspotenzial und nochmal ich wir haben
darüber gesprochen auch über die
Vorteile die das alles hat dann würde
das doch bedeuten dass macht ohne
Gesetze ist gefährlich das war schon
immer so gewesen ja aber was bedeutet
das denn dann konkret jetzt mal auf auf
zum Beispiel auf Twitter übersetzt und
weil es genau um diese Reizfigur Maske
geht also was ich zum Beispiel
interessant finde ist die Amerikaner
mögen ja eigentlich keine Monopole wir
sind ein reagieren naja sehr viel
allergischer als die meisten
europäischen Länder und die Amerikaner
haben in ihrer Geschichte ja sehr gerne
schon mal Monopole zerschlagen die haben
die filmindustriemeister schlagen die
haben die telefonindustrie und die haben
sie zerschlagen sie haben die
Ölindustrie ist 300 Euro zerschlag ja
und es ist natürlich seit langer Zeit
immer die Rede diese unglaubliche Macht
die die gar fast Google Amazon Facebook
und Apple haben dass man die in dieser
Form doch eigentlich gar nicht verstehen
lassen kann weil so viele
Monopolstellung da drin
und da gibt es viele Liberale ja das
sind wahrlich keine Kommunisten das sind
überzeugte marktliberale die sagen das
müsste eigentlich zerschlagen werden
jetzt geht das große Problem dieses
altmodische Instrument Zerschlagung ja
und die Welt der Digitalisierung des
zweiten maschinenzeitalters die passen
nicht besonders gut zusammen ich kann
meinen Namen austauschen ich kann mich
in 34 Zellen teilen ja das sind ja keine
richtigen Firmen wie ich immer sage sind
investitionspools das ist nicht so wie
wir früher sagen wir mal Krupp ja und
dann hätte man hingehen können und dann
könnte man sagen können die und die
Maschinen und das kannst du nicht machen
und die schwarze stellt sie nicht mehr
her und so weiter das ist natürlich in
der digitalen Welt alles sehr sehr viel
komplizierte man müsste sich also
überlegen was wäre eine Zerschlagung 2.0
und dann könnte man unter dem
Gesichtspunkt hat Elon Musk nicht zu
viel Macht auf dem Mediensektor mit
solchen instrumentarischen vielleicht
auch dagegen vorgehen und sagen es geht
nicht ich fand das interessant dass das
kartellrechtlich möglich war dass er das
gekauft dann das ist wahr und würdest du
sagen abschließend gefragt Richard
jemand wie Trump zum Beispiel der dann
immer mal verbannt wurde von von Twitter
88 Millionen Follower habe ich meine die
die haben bei alledem was da 216 und
folgende passiert ist hat Social Media
eine große Verantwortung und Twitter im
Besonderen ist es richtig dass der dahin
zurückkehren darf sollte der soll
Meinungsfreiheit wenn wir das ernst
meinen uneingeschränkt gelten bis zu dem
Punkt an dem es strafrechtlich relevant
ist oder sollten wir sagen wir geben
unseren Person Trump verdammt geht nicht
weil dann könnte ich hingehen und könnte
jeden verdammen also dann und ich kann
er dann auch noch eine tausend Lügen
Existenz mit falschen Namen aufbauen und
so aber sagen wir mal wenn es jetzt
hingeht und wir machen jetzt so eine
Todesliste und sagen diese 500 Leute in
der Welt oder dürfen hier bei Twitter
nicht und so weiter das wäre ein
komisches Verfahren das wird mir
eigentlich nicht gefallen der würde eher
gefallen dass man hingeht und bestimmte
Sachen die abgesetzt werden und die
dramatische Lügen sind wohl die dazu
führen dass in die gigantische schaden
da entstehen kann und so dass man das
dann so anders nimmt und jemand weiß
nicht die partiell zu sparen oder auf
Zeit oder irgendwas so in diese Richtung
aber Personen auszugrenzen ich glaube
das kommt ja am Ende die Diskussion nach
welchen Kriterien wird das was
wahrscheinlich darüber was das
entscheidet entscheidet das am besten
ähm persönlich der sich dann überlegt
wenn die der wird gesperrt und der wird
nicht gesperrt dann wird Nancy pilo sie
gesperrt oder die nicht leiden kann und
so also da ist ja der willküre geöffnet
also mit diesem einfachen sperren kommen
wir glaube ich nicht weiter auch das ist
so ähnlich wie mit dem zerschlagen ne
irgendwie auch so ein aussperren also so
in der Schule wo man rausgeschmissen
wurde wenn man gestört hat ich glaube
das sind auch nicht die richtigen Mittel
und man macht Leute dann natürlich zu
märty ne ganz nebenbei ja ich glaube
dieses Thema wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen ich weiß nicht wie schaust
du da Richard mit mit dem du hast von
angedeutet dass du einen
älterer
mittlerweile bist dann reiferer älterer
her so mit mit mit mit der Erfahrung von
na ja noch nicht aber knapp 60 Jahren
wie schaust du auf das was da so
passiert ist also die die Art und Weise
wie sich Informationen heute verbreitet
die Frage was das mit unserer
Gesellschaft macht wie schaust du als
Philosoph da drauf ja ich glaube einfach
dass das so eine so eine Welt ist die
uns noch überfordert wir haben also
Instrumente in der Hand die wir nicht
richtig nicht richtig beherrschen und
ich glaube das gehört bei technischen
Informationen ja eigentlich immer dazu
also als die Dampfmaschine kamen
Industrieproduktion häufigen ja begann
einen so unfassbar brutaler Kapitalismus
der die Leute bis auf die Knochen
ausgebeutet hat Kinder in Bergwerke
gesteckt ja in in den baumwollfabriken
feinste weisenhäuser verheizt und und
und und und heute haben wir
ein in Deutschland ja den vielen
westlichen Ländern unvergleichlich mit
damals verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit
Menschen in der Industrieproduktion
Dienstleistungsgewerbe sowieso und so
weiter und so weiter also gigantischer
menschheitsfortschritt und hier stellt
sich natürlich eigentlich genau die
gleiche Frage also ist wie schaffen wir
das dass allmählich zu zivilisieren
damals war der Motor die Gewerkschaften
nein die Gewerkschaften haben die
historisch positive Rolle gespielt
unausgesetzten Druck zu machen Gründung
der SPD Arbeiterpartei und so weiter das
quasi Stück für Stück die industriellen
nachgeben mussten und die
Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern
das heißt also ist ein eindrucksvolles
Beispiel für sozialen Fortschritt und
ich denke mir brauchen wir nicht auch
sowas wie sozialen Fortschritte im
virtuellen Raum das werden nicht die
Gewerkschaften aber es werden die
spielen in der Zukunft wahrscheinlich so
nicht nur noch eine untergeordnete Rolle
aber es werden andere Überlegungen da
sein wie zivilisieren wir das was heute
technisch möglich geworden ist und wenn
ich dann so was sehe wie diese
gigantische macht die sich in den Händen
eines einzelnen verbirgt dann denke ich
das war zumindest zum einen
eindrucksvoller Schritt in die falsche
Richtung aber vielleicht muss man erst
eine ganze Weile in die falsche Richtung
laufen ja und vielleicht muss man
richtig gegen die Pumpe laufen um zu
erkennen wie man es besser machen wenn
das natürlich rechnen wenn man wenn du
das gerade die lange Linie da so ziehst
meine früher war der mächtige der den
Grundbesitz kontrolliert hat dann waren
die mächtigen die die fabrina
kontrolliert haben und heute sind die
mächtigen die die Daten kontrollieren ne
riecht so einfach das ist richtig
richtig und es ist so dass wir keine
richtigen Kontrollmechanismen für die
haben die die Daten kontrollieren und
dabei müssen wir bei Daten noch mal
unterscheiden ne also Industrie Daten
sind noch was ganz anderes als Daten
über Menschen so richtig na also
personenbezogene Daten sind was ganz
anderes als industriearten und während
wir im Umgang mit industriedaten enorme
Wertschöpfungen produzieren können es
ist die Frage ob der Umgang mit
Personendaten und das ist ein Thema was
michaelin beschäftigt am Ende überhaupt
zu einer wertschöpfungssteigerung führt
oder nicht einfach nur zu einer
Verlagerung
je besser ich meine Kunden ausspioniere
ja umso besser können die großen die
über diese Daten verfügen die
entsprechend ausnutzen und das Kapital
dieser Menschen in ihre Hände spielen
das vorher an viele andere Leute
gegangen ist die eben kleiner waren und
nicht in den Händen der Daten also ich
frage mich immer ob die datenökonomie
dem freien Markt eigentlich was Gutes
tut ist es nicht da machen wir aber ein
riesiges neues Passwort ja nur noch ein
Satz dazu wenn du das gerade so sagst
oder ein Gedanke den wir gerade kommt ne
wenn du überlegst also auf der einen
Seite und das ist so ein seltsamer
Widerspruch sind wir frei also wird
unseren westlichen Demokratien verlaat
und Weise wie wir es in der
Menschheitsgeschichte glaube ich noch
nie waren und auf der anderen Seite ist
immer so unfrei wie nur sonst was wir
wer wir lassen uns freiwillig auf diese
Art und Weise kontrollieren wir geben
diese Freiheit finde ich wieder sehr
fahrlässig aus der Hand ja wir tauschen
wir tauschen Komfort gegen Freiheit ja
genau ja und weil wir so viel Komfort
haben und weil der Verlust der Freiheit
sich für uns nicht sichtbar wird
machen wir das aber ich will mal
gespannt wie spätere Epochen über diese
Zeit denken werden genau Richard ich
danke Dir sehr das war danke dir bis
bald ja bis bald
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]